today uh we will be discussing the
second um American Civil War so I want
to make the you the argument that um a
conflict is very likely and so we'll be
discussing why it's likely how this war
will menit benefits itself and what will
happen after this war okay so the first
thing to know about America is that it
is a
country that enjoys violence okay you
can you can say that
Americans are
addicted to
violence okay so for example America
has
434 guns oh sorry 434 million guns
that's 1.3 guns for every one person
and the guns they have a lot of them are
like semi- machine guns okay so it's a
very um gun obsessed Society not only
that but they believe that gun ownership
is their sacred
right as Americans so the Second
Amendment of the Constitution is that
every American has the right to bear
arms um then there's American football
football have you guys seen uh American
football where guys just bang at each
other okay is it is extremely violent
sport in fact America is really the only
country that plays a sport and Americans
love football the Super Bowl is the most
watched um TV event every
year and um the game the game of
football causes a lot of psychological
injuries okay so um there are a lot of
football players who at age 30 they
either commit suicide or they will kill
someone because their brains have been
destroyed by the game okay it is
extremely violent Sport and even though
it is barbaric Americans uh love it uh
Americans also worship their history of
Wars okay they believe that fighting War
it's Noble and it's sacred okay so
second thing to know about America is
that it has a long history of fighting
Wars in fact you can make the argument
that America has been continuously at
War since its founding in
1776 okay even before that um so the
first major war that America fought of
course was the revolution right 17
1776 war of
independence and um the reality it is
that Americans believed this war was
sacred and it was a revolution in human
Affairs but if you actually look at the
history of this war you'll discover that
the Americans didn't really fight this
war for good
reason um they fought this war because
the British were taxing them but if you
think about it well the British were
providing defense they were proving Army
right so the British had a very good
Reon reason to tax the Americans but the
Americans like this so they rebelled
okay um and the rebellion was actually
the first American Civil War because
there were actually a lot of Americans
who wanted to remain in the union and so
um these loyalists a lot of them were
terrorized by extremists who wanted
Independence okay so that is the
American uh uh Revolution but after
American Revolution The Americans
embarked on something called
Manifest
Destiny and the idea of manifest destiny
is that it is God's will that America
controls all of the Americas okay North
America and South America so the
Americans embarked on a
violent colonization of all lands okay
killing many Natives and other people
to uh control America okay Manifest
Destiny and then this led to in from
1861 to
1865 the American Civil War okay which
killed 800,000 a million Americans okay
but it it was the deadliest war that
America ever fought okay much more so
than World War II and World War I in
fact more people died in this war than
in War then in World War I and World War
II combined for
America right and if you looked at the
reason for the Civil War again you're
like they didn't actually have to fight
this war okay so at the founding of the
nation America was divided into North
and
South and the difference is that North
the north um was very
industrial and the South was
agricultural
okay and because the economies were
different um the way they showed their
politics and culture and Society were
different so the north believed in free
labor meaning that you were free to do
any job you want and employers were free
to hire anyone they wanted and this
system is obviously much more efficient
because it's a it's a much better use of
man power and so this caused the north
to prosper and become very very wealthy
and expanded okay so at the start of uh
the Civil War in 1861 the North had a
population of 22 million
people okay very wealthy very powerful
The South was an
agricultural um uh was an agricultural
base economy and therefore it have to
rely on slave
labor all right
um and even though slave labor made
wealthy people very prosperous it was
not good for the economy as a whole okay
it was an inefficient use of Manpower
and at the start of the war they only
had about 9 million
people okay but what's important to
remember is that the north was an an
industrial based economy The South was
an agricultural BAS economy so in terms
of weapons Manufacturing in terms of
Logistics in terms of organization the
North had a huge advantage over the
South right now now why did they fight
the war and the center explanation is
because the north wanted to get rid of
the evil of slavery and that's not true
that's not what
happened um so at the beginning of the
founding of the nation the Constitution
permitted uh slavery okay slavery was
legal and um so the South were free to
have as many slaves as they want the
north didn't want didn't need slaves
because because it was an industrial
based um economy the problem was the
nation was expanding westwards okay the
nation was expanding West and they were
adding more States into the union and
the more states there are are um they
can send senators and representatives to
Washington DC okay and the fear was that
if these Western uh states were
proslavery then that would tip the
balance in favor of the
proslavery uh cap but if the reverse
were true if the western states were
anti-slavery
then the so the South would be
marginalized okay so for decades there's
this Fierce debate as to how to
handle um these Western States as they
were emitted into the Union one by one
okay and the solution what they call the
Missouri Compromise is that for every
one state that came in as
proslavery the other state the next
state had to be anti-slavery okay does
that make sense to maintain the balance
but the problem of course is that a lot
of these Western States had their own
opinions
so um the Western so some of these
Western States for example Kansas would
would would want to be anti-slavery
okay so for decades this was a huge
issue
politically um In America which divided
the
nation the turning point was in
1860 when Abraham Lincoln was elected
president of the United States and
Lincoln was radically anti-slavery he
believed that slavery was evil and had
to be abolished at some point okay the
rest of the world abolished slavery why
is it in America there are so many
slaves so that was Lincoln's agenda but
Lincoln was also a lawyer and he believ
that the sou legally had a right to
slavery
but over time what we can do is limit
slavery in the west and therefore over
time it maybe 100 years time slavery
would naturally cease to exist okay that
was Lincoln's plan now the S did not
like this plan and they were afraid of
what Lincoln might really do as
president so they declared
independence from the United States it
was was they basically succeeded from
the union okay and Lincoln response
invaded the South okay so basically the
Civil War
was a battle over how much power the
federal government had okay so from the
perspective of the South they were
fighting a war for their right
to freely Express their political views
okay and the north was fighting to
maintain the union slavery was not the
main issue in fact Lincoln himself said
that um if it if if I could end the war
about freeing any slaves I would do so
slavery is not is not the main issue
keeping the union intact was the main
issue okay does that make sense okay so
but again um they could have chosen to
politically
compromise they could have had
discussions right they could have even
broke
apart but uh they chose to fight a
gruesome Civil War okay so the third
thing you need to know to know about
America is that America resolves
conflicts for violence
okay it doesn't really have a history of
diplomacy it has the history of War
making okay that's how America usually
resolves um
issues so um given this history now
let's look at the conflicts in America
today to see how
serious uh the division is and the
reality is that today it's actually very
very serious far more so than in 1861
when they fought the first Civil War
okay so let's look at the division the
first major division is basically
between the halves and half knots okay
so inequality and
debt um so the wealthy the top 1% not
only do they control most of the wealth
in
America um but they also control what we
call the means of production meaning
that if new money comes into the system
they will seize it okay so basically the
12 1% have a monopoly over wealth
production and the way they make most of
their money is actually through
collecting debt okay by exploiting other
people and this is what we call a
rentier
economy okay now what exaggerates makes
this situation even worse are the
culture
wars so America is divided between
left and
right and this division actually goes
back to the very founding of America in
the 1600s okay so um in America in its
founding there's there were two opposing
Visions or Str or strands okay the first
strand are people who came to America to
build a kingdom of God a Christian
Nation that follows the laws of God okay
these are the pilgrims and the peritan
okay and we've discussed them before and
they've always been there okay and they
today comprise the right and the right
are people who believe in Conservative
Christian values okay the left but
there's also another strand of America
and these are um dissident or political
dissident and they believe in the
enlightenment they believe that reason
should be the god of human
Affairs okay and these were the founding
fathers okay the founding fathers
believed in something called theism
which is that there is a God but God
gave us the power reason and logic to
determine our own Affairs so uh the
Constitution um is is a document based
on on deism okay separation of church
and state and they want to create a
multicultural
secular
Empire okay and today it man manefit El
in the left okay
now there's
actually um a
lot of s a lot of crossover between the
left and the wealthy okay because if you
look at the left it's
usually um
Urban
liberal and college
educated okay and
Coastal okay and these are the people
usually with all the
money okay so the inequality only makes
the culture wars much worse and so the
right feel left out okay another major
division in America that's important is
the one between
Empire and
democracy meaning that there are many
people in America who
benefit from America being an
Empire but the rest suffer from the fact
that America is an Empire okay so for
example the wars in Afghanistan and Iraq
made Wall Street very rich right but it
was the poor the right who sent their
sons to fight in these wars and who lost
their lives or lost a limb okay it was
the poor who were
taxed in order to fund these wars and
it's the poor who must pay off the debt
from these
wars okay so the right is also very
isolationist meaning like they don't
want to fight these wars they think that
America should be an island it should
not intervene in the Affairs of the
world okay so there are a lot of
Divisions in uh
America the problem today is that
there's no actual
solution to any of these divisions okay
and and the reason why um there are
three major reasons why um a civil war
would probably break out okay the first
major reason is the
over
militarization of
America and so what this means is that
okay first of all we've already said
that in America there are
434 million
guns right in private hands so every
individual has access to one or two guns
that's the first problem second problem
is that if you go to a small small town
in
America and you look at like the police
there you think that okay a small town
it's safe they should have I don't know
pistols right in fact they have armored
vehicles some of them they have tanks
they have helicopters they have
bulletproof vests they have machine guns
okay they got all this from the
military so that's just like a local
police force I'm not even talking
about uh the
state militias okay the National Guard
these guys are basically an army onto
themselves then you have federal
agencies like the
FBI and the CIA and home
security okay NSA okay there's dozens
dozens of these federal agencies they
themselves are their own Army meaning
that the FBI and the CIA all have their
special
forces tanks helicopters Jets bombs
missiles
okay so these guys can go to war against
each other okay then you have the US
military the US military is divided into
um the Army the Air
Force the Marines the Navy okay and then
have some something called a space force
okay okay all right to show you how
powerful the uh US military is okay
let's look at the top five air forces in
the world okay the top five institutions
or countries with the most powerful Air
Force in the world who's number
one who's number one do you
think US Air Force
right who's number two do you guys know
the top five air forces in the world
number one would be the US Air Force
right who's number two do you
think guess take a guess who's number
two yeah okay russan actually number
three okay the Russian Air Force will be
number three who's number two
though H the UK the British right nope
okay number two is actually the US
Navy who's number number three is Russia
number four is
who can you guys
guess the US
Army and who's number
five can you guys
guess it's the US
Marines okay so four of the
top five Air Force in the world are an
arm of the US
military okay number one is the US Air
Force number two is the US Navy number
three is Russia the entire country of
Russia okay number four is the US Army
number five is the US
Marines that's how powerful America is
but then you have special
forces um and again we've disced special
forces in this class before and we said
that special forces are good
for um special circumstances like for
example hijackings okay or covert
operations the problem with special
forces is they cannot be controlled okay
so for example in Mexico the people who
run the drug drug cartels are former
Special Forces okay do you understand
the people who run the drug cartels in
Mexico and who commit the most violence
in the world are former members of their
special forces that's why you want to
limit your special forces okay so in the
year
2000 America had
38,000 Special Forces today it has
70 uh 2,000 or 73,000 I can't remember
okay that's a lot of Special Forces
these guys are trained in demolition
destroying buildings
they're they're an army unto themselves
okay it would take exactly a thousand of
these guys exactly a thousand of these
guys to overthrow the US government
okay and guess what Delta Force which is
the most elite um special force unit in
America has exactly 1,000 members so you
you have this guy who runs SLE force and
he's like I want to over the I want to
over the US government for whatever
reason he can do so because they're so
powerful okay so I think Special Forces
it's just a bomb waiting to explode so
the first major issue is this the over
over militarization of America where
anyone who has access to weapons can
choose to start a war okay that's the
first problem second problem is the
breakdown
of
narratives okay so a
nation is a fiction a narrative that
everyone believes in and there are
certain
narratives that have keep have kept
America United Okay so for example the
first narrative is the American
dream right the equality of opportunity
um so that as long as you work hard and
you play by the rules you will succeed
in America right that's the American
dream guess what guys No One Believes In
this anymore okay and the reason why is
the inequality in America as well as the
cultural
Wars so if you're a young person you
don't believe that if you work hard you
own a house and you will be wealthy you
don't believe that okay you think like
the game is stacked against you you
believe that Washington is corrupt it
only serves the interest of the rich you
believe that the wealthy have stole
everything they've monopolized
wealth and you believe that whatever
money you make will be stolen by the
rich and by the government okay so
there's actually no reason to work hard
so this idea
that if you work hard you will succeed
it's dead okay now the new American
dream is how do I stay out of
debt right if you are if you're a
college graduate you have tens of
thousands of dollars in
debt consumers have thousands of dollars
in credit card debt you can no longer
afford houses if you buy a house you
can't pay off the mortgage okay okay so
this idea of the American dream it's
basically dead for most
people then you have the narrative that
America is
good okay you believe that
America represents democracy it
represents Liberty it defends Freedom
all around the world guess what guys
most people in America don't believe
this anymore okay so for example in the
on the
left people are taught that America is a
nation founded on slavery violence and
War America is a force of Destruction
and
evil okay that's what people on the left
are taught people on the right believe
that America is an imperialist power
that goes around and destroys countries
for no reason
okay so most people don't actually
believe that America is a Force for good
anymore right uh and then you look at
what's happening in Israel right well
more young people now believe that
America is a force of evil in the
world the other narrative that's really
important is that is The Narrative of
liberalism and the idea of liberalism is
is that even though we have differences
there are mechanisms for us to work out
our differences for
example the right to freedom of speech
okay freedom of speech you can say
whatever you want okay then you but
what's important is to
debate the opponent and come to a
compromise based on logic evidence and
the facts okay so for the longest time
liberalism was what brought the left and
the right together okay
liberalism tried to be in the
middle but
now liberalism is dead okay and the
reason why is in
2016 Donald Trump became president of
the United States and the Liberals
America went
crazy they could not believe that Donald
Trump could be um elected so they came
to believe that the problem was
democracy
itself the problem is that people could
not be reasoned with therefore
liberalism makes no sense if people are
stupid if people cannot be reasoned with
why give them freedom of speech why let
them debate
why let them vote okay so liberalism
today is
dead so the stories that basically bind
the country together no longer work okay
does that make sense then the third
problem
is
breakdown of
Authority or
institutions okay
what kept the country together was the
fact that people believed that the
Elites in power knew what they were
doing and they were um they cared about
the well-being of the nation and of the
people okay but recent events have shown
this isn't true okay so for example the
wars in Afghanistan and Iraq
right well why did America fight these
wars for no
reason then you had the 2008 financial
crisis where the banks
basically stole from the nation stole
from the poor and kept the money and
everyone everyone was screwed
okay then you had
Co right covid where the the government
the elite locked down the entire nation
kids could not go to school
the poor could notot go to work and make
a
living and there was actually no
evidence that Co was actually
dangerous
okay
then um the government made everyone
take a experimental
vaccine and people were like why are we
doing
this okay so Elite actions over the past
20 years have made people cynical of
power so that to in today's world
there's actually in in today's America
there's no more trusted institution okay
before you had
um
government you had media like New York
Times Washington Post you had science
you had
military okay
um and the government is like they're
just corrupt right screw them Congress
is just hated by everyone
okay the mil the media is just speaks
for the rich they're always lying to us
right New York Times Washington Post CNN
they're just
liars okay so no one trusts the media
anymore then you have science and you
can't you can't trust science because of
Co right science made everyone take an
experimental vaccine for no reason so
you can't trust science anymore the
military goes fights Wars for no reason
look at Ukraine look at Israel okay so
in other words there's no institution in
America that can bring people together
anymore they're not trusted oh and also
sorry I forgot about
universities before people start
universities but not anymore because of
the culture wars
right so that's the problem in America
right now you have three things going on
you have the militarization of society
where anyone can start a war for no
reason okay second is that you have a
breakdown of the stories and narratives
that bind the country together so no one
knows what it means to be American
anymore and number three is there are no
more authority figures no more
institutions that can bring people
together they can only divide
people okay
okay does does that make sense okay and
this is getting worse
so um we we've seen the government fall
the media fall the science fall military
fall universities but there's also the
justice system right the
courts and this is falling as well
because of Donald Trump remember like
last week in New York City Donald Trump
was convicted guilty of 34 felonies okay
and so people are now no longer trusting
the court system the justice system okay
so again all these sacred institutions
in America they're all falling one by
one okay so does does this make sense so
if you look at all this okay America's
History of Violence the conflicts raging
in America the fact that there America
no longer believes in institutions and
in narratives okay then the most likely
outcome is a civil war okay does that
make sense so any questions so
far yeah so um s asked a very good
question like how powerful is the
American president the answer is that
he's really a figurehead okay he's not
he's not that powerful
okay U because because as Seline points
out uh Power is diffused in America in
institutions and if these in
institutions are corrupt there's very
little the president can do about it and
that's why this year in November 2024 we
will see the lowest turnout one of the
lowest turnouts of Voters in American
history because people just give up okay
right four years ago they came out to
kick TR out of office because they
believe that Trump was a threat to
democracy and with Biden people
recognize that no it's all corrupt just
burn the system down who
cares okay so no one cares who's
President anymore and that and that's
going to help Trump in
November okay any more questions before
I move on
okay so SEL asked a question what will
the Civil War look like okay that's a
very good question and the answer is it
will look nothing like the first Civil
War okay because in the first Civil War
there was clearly a division that the
divided the nation okay a proslavery
camp and an anti-slavery
Camp
okay but as we can see from uh this
chart in today's America
conflicts uh there are many sorts of
conflict there are many sorts of
factions in America okay and therefore
the Civil War will not be one event but
it will be a series of violent episodes
over 10 20 50 years okay does that make
sense so let's go over these events okay
the first thing that would probably
happen are sort of
riots and unrests okay and we saw that
during the first Trump presidency uh
because because of the George FL Floyd
black lives matter protest okay so we'll
see more of that when Trump becomes
president where um people are so angry
at this election they'll start rioting
okay and there'll be a lot of
unrest um second is basically civil uh
conflict meaning that neighbors take
guns against each other so um America is
divided between left and right but there
actually pockets America where left and
right are very closely they live very
closely with with each other okay so
it's very it's very likely that take
arms against each other but these would
be small isolated Affairs where maybe
one or two people get killed okay so you
have civil conflict then you
have state or city
secession secession sorry I spelled this
wrong secession meaning that you have
maybe one City New York City City or one
state California and they're so
disgusted by the State of Affairs they
declare independence okay they succeed
and guess what they have their own Army
their citizens are armed okay but
they'll most likely be attacked by other
states or different groups okay so that
would be a more major conflict okay then
you have uh what we call
insurgencies so
basically um
a political group who's trying to form a
government of some sort okay so it's
possible that you have Christian
extremists or maybe leftwing extremists
who try to overthrow the government of I
don't know uh New York or Virginia okay
right then you have um
kudas where basically arm of the
military maybe Special Forces most
probably Special Forces tries to
overthrow the
government okay um so I think in because
of the way things are structured in the
next civil war um all these things will
happen at once okay and they'll build on
top of each
other but remember that America it's a
very large country so there could be a
lot of places where it's very peaceful
there's no war
okay but there could also be some places
like New York City or Los Angeles where
um there's just a lot of violence going
on
okay does that make
sense um okay so whether or not the US
government is over Throne that's a very
specific question I don't know okay the
only thing I can do is like look at the
structural forces and conclude that a
civil war is very likely and that the
Civil War it will be very chaotic but
what will actually happen in the Civil
War I don't actually know okay okay but
I but what I will say is that given the
nature of the Civil War I think like
once the war
ends um the outcome will be that America
becomes a
Christian
isolationist
theocracy okay and the reason is very
simple Okay the reason is very simple
remember that at the founding of America
there were two opposing visions of the
country the first was to build a
multicultural secular Empire to spread
democracy and freedom around the world
okay that was the first vision and
America has achieved this Vision okay
and it's led to all this conflict the
second Vision which is also very strong
is to believe in America as a white
Christian Nation dedicated to the rule
of
God okay uh and so I think there will be
extremists in America who will want to
push this agenda and why would they win
why would they win why are they most
likely to win this war
okay the answer is they're most willing
to fight and to die for what they
believe in okay and guess what guys um a
lot of these people happen to work in
law enforcement the military and
especially the Special Forces
okay all right does that make
sense so that's what I think would be
the most outcome of the Civil War when
it ends but I don't know when it will
end okay and I I I don't actually know
what happens in between the specifics
okay all right so any more questions
before I finish okay the last thing I
want to talk about is the specifics of
how the Civil War will start okay what
will ignite this war okay yeah yeah
Peter
um okay so Peter asked a great question
which is universities in the past few
decades have become more political sized
okay meaning like they're not actually
interested in teaching you how to think
they're interested in teaching you how
to think a certain way okay which is
very uh leftwing okay so for
example um the belief that America is a
society based on violence and the and
slavery and the exploitation of
minorities okay so there's a lot of
correctness in universities
today um and Peter asked the question
okay so what what can we learn in
University and the answer is that even
though universities have become more
politicalized your education in
university is up to you okay why because
University is very big there are a lot
of professors and there are a lot of
different classes okay and so it's up to
you to structure your own learning and
to be clear about what you want to learn
and to understand uh the limitations of
the education you're getting okay does
that make sense all right any more
questions before I move
on okay that's a great question okay um
so Jack asked a question like who are
the ones who don't trust universities
and the answer of course error people
who are left out of the system right so
people who don't actually go to
university the people on the right
basically okay people on the left uh are
composed mainly of college educated
individuals who are wealthy okay um but
at the same time there are many
University who do not like what's going
on so there's a faction within the
university professors and students who
are dismayed by what's going on okay but
they're only a but they're only a small
fraction of the total population okay
most universities have become extremely
extremely
leftwing okay uh any more questions
before I move
on okay all right so so uh so I'll move
I'll move on to my next point which will
answer your question okay all right now
let's talk about
how the Civil War will actually start
okay and it's will start with the
election of Donald Trump the re-election
of Donald Trump and the reason why is
that Trump is a unique figure in
American politics the reason why is that
he
embodies the culture wars okay meaning
like the people on the left all that
they hate in the right manifest
themselves in Donald Trump okay he's
white he's sexist he's racist he's a pig
and he doesn't apologize for any of this
he has no manners he's not
educated he has no
values okay all the left hate in the
right manifest themselves in the body of
Donald
Trump and that's why the right
loves Donald Trump right because their
enemies hate
them okay so and for many the right
Donald Trump is the Messiah okay he's
the Jesus and everything that's happened
in the past eight nine years for them
has confirmed that Donald Trump is
Jesus okay and the reason why is Donald
Trump ever since he became elected um be
elected president pres the left the
elite has been trying to persecute him
right remember that when he became
president um they were spreading the
media was spreading stories that Trump
was a Russian agent he was a spy of
Putin that's just nonsense there's no
evidence of that but people believe that
okay then they were trying to say uh
then they tried to use the justice
system against Donald Trump right they
impeached him twice they raided his
house okay the trying to send him to
prison a judge in Colorado tried to
remove Donald Trump from the ballot
meaning you couldn't vote for
him so everything that the elite has
done has been to destroy Donald Trump
and therefore people in the right think
this guy is our savior he's Jesus he's
the Messiah okay does that make sense
now let's F out this if you
are the on on the left if you're the
elite if you're the rich and you hate
Donald Trump there's exactly one way and
only one way you can destroy Donald
Trump forever
how you guys
know what would you do if you really
wanted to destroy Donald Trump and you
were like rich and liberal and
Elite you go to Donald Trump you have
dinner
together and you say three words and you
will you will destroy him what are these
three
words okay what you say to Donald Trump
what you do is you
say let's be
friends right why would that destroy
Donald
Trump what's the appeal of Donald
Trump why why why why do people on the
right love him why does Maga love him
because that's right because he is an
outsider he's the enemy of the elites
because the elites hate him okay so all
the elites have to do is become Donald
Trump's friend right invite Donald Trump
to his parties say all these nice things
about him on the media and support
Donald Trump and then and then people on
the right will be like oh we were fooled
into thinking Donald Trump is an
outsider when he's actually Insider okay
then you've destroyed Donald
Trump why won't Elite do
that no it's not it's not because
they're too proud it's because
what it why why won't they do that like
why won't they become friends with
Donald Trump and you know it's something
that Donald Trump probably wants as well
right yeah it's hatred okay you
understand it's pure hatred I want to
kill this guy okay do you understand so
you can see like the hatred between left
and right remember that Donald Trump
manifests all the right okay all the
cultural values of the right okay and
and so people the elite hate this guy so
much that they willing to do anything to
get rid of this guy But the irony is
that because of this anger and
hatred they're doing everything to make
Donald Trump Invincible okay this is
what we call TDS or Trump derangement
syndrome the
inability to recognize who Donald Trump
is and the inability to think
properly about how to deal with Donald
Trump
okay the not only are the Elite trying
as hard as they can to destroy Donald
Trump but at the same time they're
destroying the institutions and the
narratives that hold America together
okay ever since Donald Trump became
president the mainstream media New York
Times CNN Washington Post have
relentlessly attacked him therefore
destroying their
credibility okay therefore destroying
liberalism it's the elites themselves
who have destroyed the narratives and
the institutions that b American
together and it's all because of the
hatred of Donald Trump okay does that
make sense so it's really going to be
this hatred of Donald Trump that
drives the second American Civil War
okay all right does that make sense all
right so let's see how this will play
out okay so what will start this Civil
War is is in November Trump becomes
president okay so Trump becomes
president
and the first thing that Trump has to
figure out when Once to become president
is how does he stay in office for the
rest of his life Okay the reason why is
the moment he leaves office he's going
to be sued he's going to be put in jail
he's going to be attacked by the elites
okay so the first thing he needs to
figure out the only thing that he
actually cares about is how do I stay in
office for the rest of my life okay now
there's a trick he can use to stay in
office for the rest of his life okay
because the
Constitution says that you can only
serve two terms as
president but there's nothing in the
Constitution that
says you can't serve as vice president
for as long as you want you understand
so what Trump can do in 2028 is have his
son run for president and he becomes the
vice president but everyone will know
that he'll still be the president you
understand does that make sense to you
guys that's a trick he can use in 2028
okay because I guarantee you the moment
he steps in the white house he's like
okay how do I stay in here forever
because it's either the White House or
the jail house for me okay so he's going
to think about how to stay in office and
the easiest thing he can do is have his
son uh da Jr run as president he he he's
runs as vice president okay but everyone
will know that he's still a president
does that make sense okay so you can
imagine that if Trump does
this then this will create a
constitutional crisis in the country
where like the
left um the left go insane okay you're
talking about like riots on the streets
civil conflict maybe New York City and
Boston be like we're leaving the union
if Trump becomes president again okay um
you have these insurgencies all around
America to rebel against the Trump
regime okay so this is something that
Trump can do in 2028 okay another
question then is what can he do to
ensure that he wins in
2028 and the E's answer is in his in
over the next two three years start a
war with Iran okay right start a war
with Iran the reason why this is
important is that by starting a war with
Iran he wins over the Deep state right
he wins over the Israel Lobby he wins
over the military industrial complex he
wins over a lot of the elite on his
side okay does that make
sense now we discussed that America
cannot possibly win a war war against
Iran this war can only drag on right now
let me ask you this question why would
this be good for Trump if this if this
in 2028 okay he he's running for vice
president his son is President is
running for president and the war in
Iran is dragging on or it seems the
United States is going to lose this war
why
would this be good for Trump in 2028
the entire Society the entire left is
mobilized to get rid of trump
right because they want this war in Iran
to
stop so why would this war be good for
Trump in
2028 okay I had to say this okay but
there's going be a group of people who
are doing anything they can to ensure
that this war continues and who are they
within
America there's a group of people who
are the most pro-empire of everyone else
and they fight a war they want war to
they want to win the war and they
they'll do anything they can to ensure
that this war is won and who are
they which which part of the
military exactly okay do you understand
Special Forces okay these guys are the
problem Special Forces
okay in 2028 if there's a war in
Iran and Trump is running again to M to
maintain the War I guarantee you these
guys and other steep State members will
come in and commit acts of terrorism
acts of political
assassination to ensure that Trump wins
okay you also have election meddling
election interference okay they're going
to cheat on behalf of
trump you
understand but if that's the case okay
if 20228 is an extremely contested
election then we can imagine at that
point the entire Civil War blows up
okay New York City declares independence
Boston declares independence California
declares
independence you have all these Wars
breaking out Across
America
okay
meanwhile the United States is still
fighting this pointless war in Iran
right so I think that's what's going to
happen all right any questions or is
there anything you're not clear
about okay um so the US military so so
Jack's question is like who are the US
Military Support okay so the US military
is very complicated because because you
know it's divided into a lot of
different departments okay so the
military is not one Beast it's like many
many different beasts okay um second
problem is how the leadership of the
military is actually extremely
Democratic but the base the soldiers are
extremely Republican okay so you have
this ideological mismatch between the
leadership the generals and the soldiers
okay um so it's most likely that given
these differences the military does not
intervene
in the Civil War okay but there is a
group in the military who has the leeway
the flexibility and the will to
intervene in this war and its Special
Forces right because they not controlled
by bureaucracy does that make
sense so the question then is who will
Special Forces support and the answer is
that different special force units will
support different factions okay that's
why the Civil War can be extremely
violent right because Americans will
have access to guns but these guys have
access to Jets and
bombs and tanks okay does that make
sense plus like like again each one of
these guys can be a general in the war
okay Special Forces is extremely
powerful okay does that answer your
question Jack okay any more questions
okay so SEL ask a great question okay
and this is actually the most
fundamental question it is really
impossible for the left to imagine that
Donald Trump will attack Iran
because Trump is seen as extremely
anti-war okay Donald Trump when he was
when he was a first-term
president um didn't start any War Wars
and so the left is not expecting Donald
Trump to clear War because he he he
didn't do so and he's declared he won't
do so
okay but here's what we know first thing
we know is that presidents on the
campaign Trail do things radically
different from when they become
president okay every president is the
same way what you say in public before
you become president what you do as
president are two two very different
things okay that's the first thing
second thing is
that Donald Trump um has recently said
publicly that Joe Biden is not doing
enough to protect Israel meaning that he
will do more to support Israel what does
that mean it means that he'll give
Israel more weapons and he will defend
Israel against its enemies which include
Hezbollah and Iran okay that's the
second thing the third thing is that
there are now a group of billionaires
who are coalescing around Donald
Trump okay and these billionaires are uh
Miriam
adelon who is the most pro- Israel
billionaire in all of America and she
plans to give Donald Trump $90
million okay that's a lot of money but
then you also have someone like stepen
schwarzman
um and Bill Amman okay all these guys
are extremely pro-israel they're Jewish
billionaires who are extremely
pro-israel now why are they giving
Donald Trump a lot of money it's because
they want something right and what I'm
guessing is what they want is for Donald
Trump to make Nikki
Hy his vice president okay and to staff
his cabinet his government with
pro-israel individuals okay who include
uh M Mike
Pompeo M Mike
Pompeo uh and others okay in other words
don don Donald Trump
presidency uh the government is going to
be extremely anti-iran and proar with
Iran okay Niki Hill hilly a couple weeks
ago went to Israel she visited Israel
and she took a picture of herself and
what she did was she signed a bomb okay
a bomb that that was being dropped on
Gaza and said finish them America loves
Israel nickii okay she's calling for
Mass genocide against the Palestinians
that's Nicki H guys all right so um
given the way things are turning out I
imagine that nickii becomes vice
president and that's good for Trump
because she's a skap in that one right
Trump can say hey this war it's all H's
fault right okay
um
also
Trump believed that he won in 2020 okay
he won in 2020 but why did he did he
become but why did he lose the
presidency because a deep State W the
election and why did deep State wck the
election because he refused to fight
Wars so if he want become if he wants to
become president then he has no choice
but to play along with the Deep State
okay which means going to
war so a lot of what he will do as
president depends on if he picks Nikki
Hy to be VP or not we'll know in August
if he wants Nikki Hy to be uh his VP
okay but if he picks niiki Hy as VP
that's a sure sign that um he's going to
go to war with Iraq I think okay because
she'll be pushing for war with um Iran
okay but then the question is how will
Donald Trump's base react okay because
his base is actually extremely anti-
Niki heli and anti-war right um and the
answer is at first what will happen is
that the elite the mainstream media will
support Trump in this war with Iran okay
and you have a lot of uh people who
support Trump who feel who felt
betrayed okay but then over time what
will happen is that Donald Trump will
figure out how
to manipulate his base so that his base
comes back to him do you understand okay
and so there are different ways he can
do that first of all what he can do is
blame Nikki Haley in the Deep sentence
says oh I was fooled I was manipulated
I now want out of this war okay after he
wins in 2028 he can change directions
and say I want I want I now want to end
this war and make America into a
Christian isolationist theocracy
okay do you understand that that's
something that he can
do all right something something that
that he can
do
is go against Israel okay and just say
that it's Israel that
uh plan all this okay it's Israel that
conspired to trick America into going to
war he can say that and there'll be a
lot of people who say that okay it was
the
Jews who conspired against
us all right so there's a lot of things
he can
say but whatever he does all it's going
to do
is create more war okay within America
he's all he's going to do is inflame the
Civil War okay
okay no matter what he does there's
going to be people who love him and
there people who hate him and they're
going to go war with each other and
that's why I think Donald Trump as long
as he's in office the Civil War is going
to break out and it's G be very very uh
violent okay because because he's it I
mean again I don't know what it is about
Donald Trump but he brings out the worst
in
people
okay in 2016 uh before Donald Trump was
Pres president America was actually a
pretty sane place now it's insane now
it's like you can't recognize it anymore
okay now I mean I'll be honest with you
okay um I am very much on the left okay
I think like a person on the left and I
my values are extremely liberal left
values okay and in
2016 when Trump became president I was
traumatized I believe the world had
fallen apart okay I believe the world
was destroyed everything that I believed
in was
destroyed and it took me a long time to
step out of the trauma but you know I
still have these liberal friends and I
gu and like the moment we talk about
Trump if I if I say anything nice about
Trump which is like okay you know what
Trump is an idiot but but he's
representing people who feel
marginalized they become so angry with
me okay like like like I feel insecure
or unsafe I feel as though they're about
to punch me okay if I say anything nice
about Donald Trump then people will want
to punch me okay and like I'm their
friend I've known him for like decades
and they know that like I hate Donald
Trump as much as anyone okay but you're
not allow to say anything nice about
Donald Trump among liberals and leftist
people Okay so
so does that answer your question Seline
okay so it's complicated
okay um but I think this
is what could happen right any more
questions um okay
so this goes back to the question of
Empire okay so again unfortunately there
are a lot of Americans who benefit from
Empire okay that's what they that's
that's why they want war with Iran
especi so these people work on Wall
Street they work for the military
industrial complex and they tend to live
in the
suburbs
okay okay any more
questions is is there anything you're
not clear
about does this does this argument make
sense to
you does the logic here make make sense
to you
guys okay is there anything you don't
you want me to
clarify okay all right so um next class
we'll talk about what happens afterwards
okay so what this is telling us that is
that America is going to retreat from
the world but when America Retreats from
the
world um it we we will live in a
multi-polar world
okay so next class we'll discuss what
this multipolar world looks like okay